This year, you have the opportunity to go
to Davos for the World Economic Forums' Annual Meeting
And put forward your idea.
My name is Rebeccea McQuigg
I'm Julia Lalla-Maharajh
Hi I'm Sloane Berrent
I was chosen to go to Davos in 2009 to attend Davos
I was the 2010 MySpace WallStreet Journal Citizen Journalist
I was chosen in 2010 to attend Davos
One of the key topics this year's agenda is how
everyone can benefit from economic prosperity - inclusive growth
Did you know that the global economy is worth over 70 trillion dollars,
and yet over 3 billion people live on less than $2.00 a day?
How do we close this gap?
Upload and submit your video describing ONE idea
that you think can drive inclusive growth.
If your idea is chosen, you'll have the opportunity to
present it in front of people who can make it real.